ET: The mitotic spindle, the whole thing, the proteins and the chromosomes,
was isolated in 1952 by Mazia and Dan.
And this brought forward the hope that we would be able
to understand what this was made of and maybe how it works.
And there was a period of perhaps ten years in which many of us came,
isolated spindles, tried to isolate from them the proteins,
and we failed because the structure was too complex. There were too many proteins.
And we just didn't have an assay.
We knew that there was a fibrous protein, that is to say a filament,
because from the work of Shinye Inoue, he had shown that the spindle is birefringent.
And therefore it must be, to some extent, a parallel array of filamentous proteins.
And we wanted to find out what that filament was.
And Shinye Inoue will also give a talk on this subject,
which I suggest strongly that you listen to as well.
So we tried and failed both on sea urchin eggs and growing cells in culture
and isolating the proteins and nothing came out of it. There were too many things.
So we had the idea that maybe we could use a drug called colchicine.
A whole book had been written on colchicine, and it was known to be specific,
apparently specific, in blocking cell division,
although there were controversies as to what this really meant.
Maybe it didn't block cell division, maybe it stimulated cell division.
But everything suggested that this was a compound
that we might be able to use if a long shot suggestion
might be correct that this specific molecule
was binding in some way, or interfering in some way,
with the action of the formation of the spindle fibers.
And so we set out to synthesize tritium labeled colchicine
because this would allow us to see if it was binding to something in the cell.
This could be done by a method which was non specific, but easily done,
and we purified the tritium labeled colchicine.
And indeed showed that it was taken up by cells in tissue culture,
as well as into sea urchins eggs, which we had some sea urchins in the lab too,
and that it was concentrated by the cell,
which told us that it was binding to some component that was there
in relatively large amounts.
It couldn't be an enzyme. It had to be, possibly, a structural protein.
So it seemed like this was worth trying.
It seemed, on the other hand, that the chances of this project succeeding were very, very small
because it was a long shot idea, and I didn't like at first to give it to a graduate student,
to work on because he could have wasted two or three years and got nowhere.
But anyway, Gary Borisy joined the lab around that time
and well, what did you want to do, Gary, when you got to the lab?
GB: I mean before getting on the project I was an undergrad at the University of Chicago
and Frank Child was one of my professors
and he was teaching biology and showed me how cells divide,
actually we saw living cells divide and I asked him rather naively,
like all undergraduates are, I suppose, well how does it work?
What's the mechanism?
And it was clear that there was no molecular understanding
of the mechanism. And this is before I learned about your lab.
I thought this is a fantastic problem to be studying,
a problem that is worth spending one's research career on.
And then after graduating and looking at graduate schools
I learned about your work with colchicine,
and I thought, "Oh my gosh, this is the molecular entree to the problem of mitosis."
So that is why I wanted to join the lab.
ET: So then what we had to do was to get an assay,
and that was to get something that bound to the protein,
we could spin it out, separate it on a column,
later put it onto DEAE filter paper
and then what we could do would be to make an extract from a cell,
spin off the particles, look at the protein,
and say well how much colchicine is bound.
And then we could do what biochemists do,
we fractionated into different test tubes,
and tested each tube to see how much colchicine binding activity,
and then we could go, because that was whole issue.
We were trying to isolate the railroad tracks,
and there was no assay for railroad tracks.
It is not an enzyme, so the whole trick here
was to find an assay. And it was a long shot bet, but it turned out
as the work went on and Gary, and also other people, Mike Shelanski, Dick Weisenberg,
developed the approaches
and then once we had figured out that it wasn't just in mitosis, but it was present all over,
and particularly in brain, and that was just, as we said,
we were testing to see if it was a distribution of binding related to mitosis.
And the brain was the control, and that changed our thinking
because clearly this was a widespread protein,
which was in mitosis, but was all over the place.
GB: Well now we know that it's a widespread protein,
but at that time when we got the brain result it was very puzzling.
ET: It was.
GB: Very puzzling. So the idea was to assay different tissues varying in mitotic index,
and the expectation was those tissues high in mitotic index
would have high colchicine binding,
brain very low in the mitotic index should be very low,
and then we got this astounding result that brain was very high.
And now the students at that time would meet around Botany Pond and talk about results,
and I remember very distinctly all, you know, my fellow students
were saying it's clearly an artifact
of this drug partitioning into the membranes of nerve cells
because they are so rich in membrane structure for all the neuronal processes.
So it's an artifact.
So we didn't immediately conclude from the brain result
that this was telling us something about the
widespread nature of the colchicine binding protein, tubulin.
We had to do further tests.
One further test was to take advantage of a previous laboratory association
that you had, as you recall, when you had your adventure in Chile
and getting squid axoplasm from the marine station in Chile,
and so you arranged to get some of that shipped up to us, and we tested it.
And we thought that if there was something important in brain,
it might be even more abundant in the pure axoplasm,
and in fact it was.
And this would also provide a test for whether or not the drug was partitioning into the membranes
because the membrane wouldn't be present in the axoplasm.
And here this positive result gave us reassurance that
maybe it wasn't an artifact, this binding in brain, but it had a deeper significance.
And it was around that time as I recall,
that I came out to Woods Hole, or around that time.
Maybe we don't have the sequence right.
But I came out to Woods Hole to learn how to isolate spindles
and extract protein from spindles,
and we also learned how to isolate sperm tails and cilia and flagella
because those systems also have microtubules,
and the word microtubules had only recently been coined
because of the introduction of a new fixative that preserved them.
Previously they hadn't been preserved.
So I learned how to isolate mitotic spindles here
and extract the protein in a more gentle way
than had been done previously
and found that we could identify the colchicine binding protein
with the same molecular properties.
We used sedimentation at that time to identify how rapidly it moved in a centrifugal field,
so it had the same properties as the colchicine binding protein from cells and from brain.
And so then we felt that there was something real here.
We had this same molecule from these different sources,
and we asked what's the structural basis? Is there a structural basis for this?
And the structure that we saw that was in common among all of these sources was the microtubule.
And that's when we made that suggestion.
ET: Yeah, because we hadn't been able to do the crucial experiment.
The crucial experiment was to take this purified protein
and turn it into microtubules. And we struggled.
GB: And we struggled with that.
ET: And I think we sometimes got some polymerization,
but we never really were able to quantitate it.
I am not sure, but I think you made-we had some microscopy,electron microscopy.
We made rings, I think.
GB: We made rings. There was also this confounding protein that we extracted from the spindles.
This very large protein that had a cylindrical shape
that at one time we thought could be the subunit of microtubules,
but it turned out to be yolk protein.
ET: Yeah, oh yes.
GB: That was another red herring and blind alley in this study.
Do you recall the discussion of the naming of this protein?
ET: Yes, we got scooped on that. We should have named the protein.
GB: We should have named the protein, but do you recall that,
I think it was in your office, and we were talking about what we should name the protein.
I recall a discussion where we said, "Well, it's a microtubule
so the subunit could be called tubulin."  With -in being the common suffix for a protein,
but it didn't sound very good to our ears,
and we reverted to the name colchicine binding protein.
Morhi, Hideo Morhi later felt that clearly the protein needed a name
and so gave the protein the obvious name.
But for several years we in the literature
referred to it only as the colchicine binding protein.
What do we take as messages that we might give to the students watching this?
ET: Well, you gave and I gave the same message: choose an important problem,
and when you are just starting out choose what you think is the most important problem.
I thought that this was the most important, and so did Gary when he joined the lab,
and that is the first important thing.
Don't work on a trivial problem.
Do something where if you succeed, you have done something really good.
And don't be confined in your thinking because we thought we were doing one thing,
isolating something specific to mitosis, because of our thinking, which was, well colchicine
is specifically blocking mitosis and therefore it is probably
some protein that's specific. And what we found as we went on,
we were completely wrong. It turned out to be not only general,
but one of the most important fibrous proteins in the cell.
GB: So I would add to that the observation that sometimes when you are doing work
you encounter apparently contradictory results.
You encounter a paradox. Don't sweep it under the carpet.
Look at it more deeply because
sometimes the deepest understanding comes from resolving those paradoxes.
Here we have Borisy/Taylor, Take 1.
ET: Drop everything we are going to work on the brain.
That's how I remember it, and then you, and well, Mike...
GB: I think with, ok, see, so this is interesting.
We may need to compare some notes and check some things for accuracy.
My recollection is that the first hints of binding in brain
actually came before I came to Woods Hole.
And part of the motivation for coming to Woods Hole was to look at isolation of the spindle again to
try to resolve this paradoxical result with the brain tissue.
GB: And then... ET: OK. GB: So we can check that, of course,
if we just look at our old papers and notes.
ET: We no longer have the notebooks.
GB: So I thought that actually came first, but maybe it doesn't matter.
Borisy/Taylor, Take 3.
GB: I recall having to beg you to get onto the project
because you said that it was not fit for a graduate student. It was too risky.
ET: Yeah, well that is worth bringing up.
GB: Do you remember that?
ET: I may have said that, yes...
GB: Also, I had to beg to go to Woods Hole,
which I think you discouraged strongly because it would be, you know...
ET: Yeah, letting your graduate student go away is..
GB: You don't want to let the graduate student leave the lab. It is sort of a fundamental principle.
Borisy/Taylor, Take 42.
GB: You decided at some point, and I guess I never asked you this.
You decided at some point that it was worth
investigating the mechanism of action of that drug.
What made you... what led you to that conclusion?
ET: Yeah, well, gee, you should have taped this. This is better than what you are going to get.
I have been.
GB: You have been?
Absolutely. I tape everything.
ET: Right well....